1 à face est en cavale rattraper en 72
heures chrono à l'autre bout de l'europe
la performance est remarquable main dans
la main police et justice se félicite
elles ont envoyé un signal fort aux
hommes violents le signal fort c'est
avant qu'il fallait l'envoyer l'empêcher
de lever le couteau contre elle c'est là
qu'on a manqué le signal fort et c'est
celui-là que nous réclamions karl
autopsie du crime pose question radié
avait déposé cette plainte pour violence
intimidations et menaces de mort
elle avait obtenu une ordonnance de
protection qui interdisait à son mari
d'entrer en contact avec elle une
ordonnance violer allègrement début août
placé en garde à vue l'homme prétend
alors avoir mal compris et s'en tire
avec une simple mise en garde
à compter de cette date il était de
nouveau entrer en contact avec elle il y
aurait une comparution immédiate
il n'est jamais rentré ensuite au
contact n'y a plus jamais plein jusqu'à
malheureusement le 30 octobre 2010 c'est
faux nous avons déposé plainte le 17
octobre le 18 octobre sans nouvelles
nous appelons l'agent de police qui suit
ce dossier et qui nous dit qu'il ne peut
recevoir razia parce qu'il ya d'autres
rendez-vous et que la dame part en congé
mais qu'elle propose que madame viennent
sans rendez vous avec un interprète
qu'elle a recevra si c'est possible si
elle est disponible
tout ça c'était le 18 octobre et le 30
octobre à vienne que ce style est pire
la victime a eu la mauvaise idée de
vouloir se défendre les vidéos des
différentes confrontations n'aurait donc
pas joué en sa faveur
ces exploitations bio laissé apparaître
une plaignante qui était très véhémente
qui repoussait alors qu'elle n'avait pas
été agressé physiquement
le mis-en-cause qui le lever le poing en
sa direction
ce qui fait que c'est un des éléments
qui étaient troublants est facile de
dire qu elle est hystérique et je repose
j'aurais dit ne seriez-vous pas
hystérique en face d'un assassin d'où
vous connaissez toute la potentialité de
vous aiguiller sur place et de le tenir
à distance est de protester et de faire
entendre sa voix pour et chez c'est
essayer de trouver du secours à essayer
de l'éloigner d'autres faits étaient
pourtant versé au dossier une agression
devant l'école notamment avait nécessité
l'intervention de la police pour autant
à aucun moment les autorités ne se
remette en question la sûreté
départementale et notamment la brigade
de protection de la famille
a fait un travail remarquable non
seulement dans cette affaire là mais
également aussi dans les faits qui ont
été rapportées qui précèdent cette
malheureuse conséquences et qui a péché
c'est évident c'est que on ne fait pas
passer la parole de la victime avant la
parole de l'agresseur pour l'association
et toutes les femmes qui fuient la
violence le dénouement de la faire
radier est un message désastreux
chaque année elles sont 250 à pousser
les portes de l'association solidarité
femmes dans le doubs